quality is in part a very technical
issue and when we talk about quality we
normally talk about things like ANR's
frame rates hardware utilization and so
on and those terms are great for helping
us to deconstruct and measure quality
but they don't necessarily help us to
connect with users and users are where
everything starts from so I want to
start there to put your user hat on for
a moment think back to the last time you
were playing a game or using an app and
it didn't work as you had expected maybe
the game framerate was erratic maybe the
app crashed whatever it was I'm sure you
had no difficulty in recalling that
experience and I'm also pretty certain
that most of you will remember the app
or the game that caused this in fact
some of you possibly don't use that
anymore you've uninstalled it as a
result so it's probably not a surprise
to any of you when I tell you that
low-quality apps are ultimately less
successful apps but let me be more
specific
since I have the data to do so apps with
the lowest ability get 26% more one-star
reviews from users than those with the
best ability users also engage 4% less
with these apps and if you're a game
developer the story's a lot worse is
actually about twice as bad users leave
you 58 percent more one-star reviews if
you're unstable and your engagement
drops by about 8% now looking at these
percentages you might think well the
numbers four and eight seem quite low
compared to 26 and the 58 but when you
think about engagement think about what
it actually means
you in your business to increase
engagement by 4% or 8% think about what
that actually translates into in terms
of monetization and you'll realize that
a 8 percent drop in engagement or even a
4 percent drop it's absolutely not
trivial these are really not small
effects play cares so much about user
experience that as we've said in the
past your apps behavior on these metrics
as well as some other core vehicles has
an impact on your discoverability in the
Play Store and on your eligibility for
editorial collections so that brings me
to something that you all have in common
they're here today which most people do
not your developers you have the amazing
power and privilege that comes with
being able to create experiences for
others on Android whether on mobile or
beyond and if you're here today
then you care that those experiences are
good ones now my colleagues and I also
care too we see it as our shared
responsibility with you the Android
developer community to create the best
possible experiences for users on Play
and we know that quality isn't an end in
and of itself
I'm sure you've all got bigger business
goals than that but what this shows is
that if you want to achieve your larger
goals
you can't avoid thinking about quality
so we have tools that we've developed on
the Play console to help you measure and
manage our quality across your
development lifecycle there are two
primary tools the pre-launch report and
Android vitals the pre-launch reports
allows you to test your app before you
release to real users
it works by installing your apk on a
number of devices in our test lab and
then we can either crawl your app
randomly or you can tell us through
scripts or game loops the paths that you
want us to take
vitals identifies issues for real users
primarily users that are in production
but also in your test tracks if you have
enough users these are tools that many
of you already using and some of you
have come to office hours to discuss and
they help you with quality not just when
you first launch your title but for
every subsequent launch as well and we
know from the feedback we've had from
developers that these tools are really
really helping you to manage your
quality in service of those larger goals
we have on a couple of case studies here
from app and game developers but we have
many more but we also know that quality
is a job that's never done and you've
given us plenty of feedback about where
we still have more work to do there are
three particular things that we hear
from you one you want us to help you
anticipate issues before they happen
before they actually reach your users -
you want us to help you prioritize the
issues that you know about which ones
should you tackle and in which order and
three having made those decisions you
actually want us to help you fix them
you need us to help you more with the
debugging so today we're going to talk
to you about some of the ways in which
we're helping you in each of these areas
and some new features that were excited
to talk about to kick things off we're
going to talk about anticipating and I'm
going to introduce my colleague James to
do so
thanks Lauren my name is James James
Heather I am an engineering manager on
the Play console team the first new
feature that we want to talk about today
in this important area of anticipating
quality issues is in the pre-launch
report now one of the key strengths of
Android is its openness and consequently
its availability on a huge range of
hardware there's a vast array of
different Android models out there
that's a good thing but of course it
comes with an Associated challenge for
developers you've tested your app or
your game on physical devices that you
have and on a variety of emulators but
how can you be sure that it will work
correctly on real end-user devices that
you don't have access to this is where
the pre-launch report or PLR comes in as
Lauren said PLR will give you
information about how your app performs
on real hardware devices based on our
crawls this is what it looks like when
you see the results of our crawl in the
Play console we can help you find
stability problems crashes ANR's and
either device specific or more general
ones a performance issues are you
consuming high levels of system
resources violations of Android
accessibility guidelines devices on
which your app just doesn't look right
we can provide screenshots for you to
check from real hardware and security
problems if your app contains
vulnerabilities that we can identify but
now we have one more signal that we've
added to help you future-proof your app
some of you will remember that last year
we made an announcement that we would
start restricting usage of non SDK
interfaces from Android P onwards in
case that doesn't ring a bell let me
briefly explain every SDK contains an
API that you're supposed to use and
internals that as a developer you are
not supposed to rely on because they
might change and that will cause crashes
or unexpected behavior the Android SDK
is no exception there are internal
methods private methods and fields that
aren't intended to be used by external
programs in P one of the changes that we
may
was to start restricting access to some
of these non SDK interfaces in order to
make sure that apps don't rely on
internal state that might change and
that should bring benefits to end-users
in terms of the stability of the apps
that they use every day we're going to
be restricting a few more of those in
Android Q to improve long term stability
even further you'll be able to find the
full list on the Android developers
website our aim is to do this in the
most stable way that we can so that we
don't crash your apps we've started by
restricting interfaces that weren't in
use at all and we're adding public
alternatives whenever we find use cases
for these restricted api's the
restrictions on devices running key will
mostly be based on the Android version
you're targeting so it doesn't mean that
users will start seeing crashes when
they update to Android Q but it does
mean that you'll want to be aware of
these issues before you release an
update that targets Q this is important
even if you're not explicitly using non
SDK interfaces in your code because we
found that in some cases the calls are
being made by third-party libraries
where you might not even be aware that
you're making those calls the blacklist
will apply to all apps on a Q device
regardless of what the target SDK is the
API is on the blacklist are ones that we
believe are not being used by any
external developers anywhere with apps
in the Play Store and the restrictions
are there to stop developers from
starting to use them so as of right now
you will be able to see Android
compatibility issues in the pre-launch
report the first change to PLR is in the
overview page where we've added some new
information you can see the extra entry
for Android compatibility in PLR where
you'll see that in this run we've
identified four errors and five warnings
further down the page you can see more
detailed and a link that brings you to
the full list of issues we've found you
can also find the information on the tab
at the top that used to be called
crashes but we're now calling it
stability because really it contains a
lot more than just crash reports and you
can see how we call out two types of
issue errors meaning use of api's that
are restricted and
cause you're apt to crash and warnings
which indicate use of AP is that are
unsupported and so could still misbehave
and might be restricted in future
versions of Android and in order to make
it as easy as possible for you to
prioritize and fix the issues we're
helped in a number of ways first off we
give the type of issue is it fully
restricted so it'll break in Android P
onwards or unsupported plan for
restriction in Android queue or
unsupported and might be restricted at
some point in the future secondly we
list each specific API that we find in
order of how often the API was called so
that it's likely that the most important
one will be at the top and finally we
give up to 20 of the stack traces where
that API was invoked so that you can
locate it in your codebase and find an
alternative approach that doesn't
involve using non SDK interfaces all of
this functionality is live now and by
the end of May you'll be able to test
your apps on devices running Android q
in the pre-launch report but there are a
couple of things you might need to think
about to get the most from this and in
fact to get the most from the pre-launch
report in general first is some apps
need credentials to get beyond an
opening login screen and as smart as our
crawler is it probably can't guess your
password what we recommend that you do
is create some test credentials that you
don't use for any other purpose and if
you then enter those credentials into
the settings tab of PLR we're then able
to use them to log on when we crawl your
app and that will only enable us to test
more of your app and go further secondly
if you're developing a game then you
might want to provide us with something
that helps us to test the key parts of
the game that are beyond the reach of a
crawler in order to do that you can
build a game loop and share it with us
you just need to ensure that you respond
to an intent of Congo gold intent or
action or test loop and use that to
initiate the game loop that means that
we can run the important sequences of
your game on devices that you don't have
access to and let you know what we find
for the visuals this is particularly
important because
you can then download the entire video
stream from PLR
and check that the game looks as it
should do on each device sadly don't
forget that knew that issues on new
versions of Android can show up not just
in compatibility results but also in
crashes in vitals you can find crashes
on a given Android release by filtering
and in PLR you can find crashes on
particular versions of Android just by
scanning down the results note that it's
really important that you do this early
since issues that you have on the latest
version of Android will take some time
to propagate to a large number of users
so you're unlikely to see them showing
up in your trends in the early days but
that's good because it gives you a
chance to fix them before they become
serious problems all of these features
in PLR are available to you and in fact
automatically run for you as long as you
submit your apk to a test track so i'd
strongly recommend that you build this
into your testing cycle once you have a
build ready for testing
upload it to an alpha or beta or
internal test track we will then run our
crawler over it and you'll have time to
acts on any findings this gives you a
strong start when it comes to this key
area of anticipating quality issues in
your apps I'm now going to hand over to
my colleague Fed to talk about
prioritizing those issues thank you
James hi my name is Federico Cole and
I'm an engineering manager on the Play
console team as Lauren mentioned earlier
prioritize in which quality issues to
address is an area that we know you
still find challenging and over time we
have developed a variety of tools in the
Play console to help you measure and
manage the app your app quality across
the development lifecycle and to
evaluate your a performance from one
update to the next among these tools
under advisers is a powerful solution to
manage the performance of your app or
game in production as a quick reminder
Android vital is an initiative by Google
aimed at improving the stability and
quality of Android devices it is powered
by the data
one more of more than 100 million user
users was opted in to share their data
with Google and video our developer
partners Android vitals cover 5
performance areas stability rendering
battery and since the last IO startup
time and permission within these areas
we have more than 15 matrix that
represents the app quality that your
users care about the most
things like crash rate and ANR and so
forth
moreover each metric can be broken down
by at least 3 dimensions like apk
version OS version and device model in
other words android vitals helps you
understand the performance of your app
as experienced on real devices in the
hands of real users in the real world
but while vitals is very powerful and a
seen great adoption since launch one
thing we heard from you is that you
needed more context to UM to help
understand how your performance stacked
up against the industry and more
importantly become your competitors when
we first launched vitals two years ago
we introduced the concept of bad
behavior
this helps show you how your apps
performance really compares with the
void with the worst offenders but this
is not enough so last year we launched
category benchmarks to help you
understand how your app or game
compares with the tops up with the top
apps in the same category or any other
category of your choosing category
benchmarks applied to all vitals and for
each of each of them we show three
percentile points they show where your
app falls in the distribution and we
also introduced category benchmarks to
other parts of the play consoles like
ratings but we keep hearing your
feedback that this is not that you want
even more concept and the category level
detail is of an aura not so this year we
are very excited to introduce a new
feature in the play
sole developer selected pure benchmarks
with this feature you can now define a
custom set of eight two to twelve peers
and see how your performance compares
across all of the android vitals and to
make things easier for you we use the
meta data we have about apps and games
to intelligently suggest a set of apps
that are similar to yours for you to
compare with however you can remove apps
from the set you can add other suggested
apps or you can search for new apps by
name or package name and privacy is very
important to us and this feature is no
exception so we have carefully designed
this product with privacy in mind
defining a set of rules to protect your
vitals and performance data however in
the interest of giving you full control
over your data we provide an option for
you to opt out of having your data
available to peers note though should
you opt out of having your or sharing
your vitals data you will be unable to
use this feature missing out on valuable
insights about your app so once you
select a set of irrelevant peers you can
compare the performance of your app with
the median of that peer set and you can
do so across all of the vitals reporting
services like the overview page details
page and as well as all the time series
reports and we are also taking the same
functionality and intelligent peer
selection from vitals and extending it
to ratings as with vitals by using a
pre-designed predefined or custom set of
up to 12 peers you can see how your
rating performs against your overtime
against your competitors and you can
even drill down to a country level and
see how your rating compared to
competitors in your most important
markets now there is a lot of
information in android vitals and we
just introduced even more so here is a
couple of key to
takeaways for you to remember first take
a moment to define a custom peer set for
your app or game a good starting point
is to pick apps that are similar to
yours from a functional or technical
perspective and while comparing your up
with competitor is very useful the peer
benchmarking can also be used to define
an aspirational peer set for your app so
a group of us that already performs at
the perform at the level that you like
to achieve
finally the apps and games ecosystem is
constantly evolving so make sure that
you come back to the to update your peer
set on a regular basis like every other
month and the final thing were calling
out it is particularly relevant to the
many of you with limited bandwidth or
who do not regularly engage with a vital
section in the Play console to ensure -
you're aware of the most important
changes to your take to your apps
technical performance make sure you sign
up to the vitals email alerts this way
you will be made aware of any critical
performance issues they need your
immediate attention so you can ensure a
solid experience for all your users in
production we are announcing more
benchmarks related features across the
entire play console this year at i/o and
if you want to learn more about this
don't miss this talk there is scheduled
for later this afternoon on the same
stage now please welcome my colleague
Joel who will tell you more about some
exciting new features in vitals and
beyond thank you
thanks fed now while peer benchmarks are
an incredible addition to the console
they're really just one of the ways that
we're working to help you with
prioritization hi my name is Joel Newman
and I'm a product specialist on the play
BD team I'm here today to talk to you
about another new way that we're working
to help you with prioritization this
time specifically as it relates to app
size as some of you may be wondering
well I didn't ask for help on app size
why should I care and fair enough
well to give it some context we know
that you as a developer are likely
spending lots of time effort and money
to acquire new users you leverage paid
and organic and easy media to drive
users to your store listing page you
optimize the assets on that page
hopefully you're doing store listing
experiments all with the intent of
increasing the likelihood that a user
will click the install button and that's
where the journey ends right now
unfortunately not there are a lot of
things that can happen between the time
a user clicks the install button and the
time they can actually fire up your app
and start to engage with it so that's
why
so--that's recently we conducted an
analysis in fact that found that almost
30 percent of all install requests are
not actually completed let that sink in
for a minute 30 percent it's pretty
surprising right well what's driving
this when we dug deeper we found that
there are a number of factors at play
but they are all generally tied to one
of three things space time and cost and
all three of these are directly tied to
app size now what do I mean by space
time and cost let me touch on each
briefly so first and arguably most
important is space the fact is that many
users simply don't have enough space on
their devices when we analyze the over
two billion devices on Play
we found that about 3 and 10 have less
than 1 gig of free storage available and
surprisingly this was not just an issue
in emerging markets this was also
prevalent in developed markets like
North America and Western Europe without
enough storage on device the install
simply fails and the larger your app is
the more likely that is to happen
now what about time now obviously the
longer download takes the higher the
probability that a user will simply lose
interest and cancel the download it also
increases the probability of disruptions
in connectivity something that's a
particular challenge in emerging markets
where networks are sometimes unstable
and the final issue is cost so
unfortunately the abundant Wi-Fi and the
near limitless data plans that most of
us are used to and simply take for
granted it's not a reality for many of
our users with limited data allowances
many users would simply cancel and
install as soon as they see the expected
download size so given that app size
impacts all of those factors the total
size of the download on device the time
to download the cost to download it's no
surprise that app size has a significant
impact on install success rates and
accordingly total overall installs but
what may be a surprise is that we can
actually quantify it we did a recent
analysis of all the installs in the Play
Store and we found that for every 3
megabyte reduction in download size
developers saw a 1% increase in total
installs and similar to what Lauren was
saying before you might look at 1% and
be like oh that's no big deal this is
not really a meaningful change let me
tell you talk to anybody in your
marketing department anybody who focuses
on user conversion this is a meaningful
change in total installs that you as a
developer have incredible control over
so given the fact that app can apps size
can have such an incredible impact on
install rate the total number of
installs and accordingly all of
the downstream business KPIs that your
business cares about this is a really
important metric for you to pay
attention to and that's why I'm proud
today to announce that we'll be
introducing app size as a full-fledged
Android vital if you navigate to the
Android vital section that consult today
you'll see that there is now a dedicated
app size sub section with a myriad of
reports to help you understand the
overall health of your app size in these
reports within the app vital section as
well as within the statistics page
you'll see two really important metrics
that you as a developer should be paying
attention to app download size which is
the size of the download that have your
apk over the wire which is directly
directly correlated with install
conversion rate as well as this app size
on device the size of your app after
your apps installation on device which
is in turn directly correlated with
uninstalls
will also show you that how your app
size changes over time so you can assess
how things like new releases might be
impacting your overall app size to bring
to parts of today's talk together fed
talked earlier about pure benchmarks and
as I mentioned app vitals app size is a
full-fledged
Android vital so accordingly I'm happy
to announce that you'll now be able to
compare your app size against that same
custom defined set of peers so you can
see how you stack up against the
competition for those of you who've
adopted the app bundle format we go even
one step further in an all-new app size
breakdown report we provide a breakdown
we provide a detailed breakdown of the
components of your app holidaying how
much of your app is code versus
resources versus native libraries so you
can assess the underlying factors that
are driving your overall app size even
more we conduct an automated analysis of
your bundle and we deliver a tailored
custom set of optimizations ordered by
expected app sizing size improvements
to help you prioritize what to work on
next so I just talked about a lot of the
information that we're gonna be
delivering in terms of app size so what
specifically should you as a developer
do I think there are two things that I
would recommend doing first is just
purely at a baseline go into the new app
size subsection in vitals get a sense of
how your app size is performing to try
to assess what impact app size might be
having on your overall business second
if you are have adopted the a bundle
format you should go into that
optimization go check out that list of
opposite optimization tips these are
concrete actionable steps that you can
take to quantifiably reduce your apps
footprint and accordingly boost your
installs now I just really glanced in a
very high-level on app size if you want
to go one or even ten levels deeper I
strongly encourage you to check out the
dedicated section session that's having
tomorrow at 8:30 a.m. on stage 2 where
we'll cover some of the details on app
size as well as the tools we're
developing to help you monitor and prove
it as led by some of our product
managers now let me quickly get back
some of our asks one of the top pieces
of feedback that we heard from you as it
relates to app health is that you love
PL PL are you love Android vitals in
terms of identifying problems but you
sometimes struggle to identify the
underlying causes well I want to let you
know that we hear your feedback this is
a consistent thing that I'm hearing from
developers all the time and today so
today I'm happy to talk a little bit
about a feature that we recently
introduced that should make debugging
significantly easier
it's called PLR and vitals linking as
Fed mentioned earlier Android vitals is
a tool to happen to help you track the
performance of your app in the wild now
because we're collecting data from real
devices in the hands of real user
we often have to redact the information
we show in the interest of user privacy
so here for example is some of the
information that we might surface for a
crash in Android vitals you'll notice
that although we show the stack trace we
redact the exception exception message
in case it contains private user
information now this information as it
is currently may be helpful at base
level for still getting at some of the
Endura underlying issues but for some of
you may still not may just not be enough
so now in contrast to vitals P
pre-launch reports on the other hand
works by running your app on devices
situated in the firebase cloud test lab
automatically navigating through the
apps app capturing exceptions and
generating logs as it goes now because
this testing is occurring in a
controlled environment we're able to
expose key information such as the
exception message that might otherwise
be redacted in vitals additionally
beyond the exception messages which can
be very helpful in debugging whenever an
anomaly such as a crash or an ANR is
detected in PLR we automatically capture
screenshots and videos these can be
super helpful resources to help
reproduce the issue and hopefully to get
at the underlying cause now wouldn't it
be great if you would go straight from a
real-world crash identified by vitals to
that same crash and PLR with all of its
associated data and resources well now
you can with the recent launch of vitals
and pilar linking whenever a real-world
crash is detected in android vitals that
we also see in a PLR test you'll see a
link between vitals and the same issue
in PLR with its associated data and
resources so you can debug more
effectively and it's worth noting that
this is not just a one-way connection
we've linked pre-launch reports and
vitals in both directions so now it
crash occurs in pre-launch reports it is
already happening in the real world
you'll be informed and you'll be able to
jump from PLR to vitals to see the
real-world impact of the crash so how
would you use this so we think this can
be really helpful for you in terms of
prioritizing prioritizing issues that I
identified in PLR because you'll be able
to quickly assess which issues that PLR
identifies or having real-world user
impacts today
so Android vitals and pl are linking is
a really powerful tool but it's really
only as powerful as the amount of your
app that we're able to crawl so I want
to quickly reiterate the message James
said earlier which if any part of your
app especially if it's at the beginning
is behind a login screen please be sure
to provide test credentials so PLR can
more effectively test your app and run
crawls
similarly vitals and pilar linking is
only actionable if we're able to
intelligently parse your stack traces so
if you're using ProGuard or another tool
to optimize or obfuscate your app be
sure to upload a mapping file for each
version this will enable us to show
useful stack traces reliably deduplicate
crashes as well as really unlock the
potential of vitals and pilar linking so
as you can see by connecting PLR and
vitals we're taking one more step
forward towards helping you with
debugging and making it easier we hope
you'll check out this feature along with
all of our new app sizes saw all of our
new app size reports as you continue
along your app health journey so before
we wrap things up I'd like to hand it
back to Lauren who's gonna talk a little
bit recap a little bit of what we talked
about today thanks Jo
[Applause]
so covered quite a number of things we
talked about vitals and the pre-launch
reports for those of you who haven't
used them before and we walk through
four new features just to help you
connect those features back to the two
tools we've got right now you can see
here that Android compatibility sits in
the pre-launch report pier benchmarks
and app size are found in vitals and
clearly PLR and fighters linking can be
accessed from either direction and I
want to give you another slide and I've
seen many of you taking photos
throughout the talk but if you haven't
taken any R this is the one slide that
you really should take a picture of here
in one place are all over the different
tips we've given you about how to make
use of the existing features as well as
the new ones success for both of us
after this talk I think is the same
thing that you come away with some
concrete next steps on something that
you can do within our health tools that
will help you reach your business goals
so please do take a picture have a look
at what we're recommending and think
about which of these actions that you
might be able to take and try when you
get back home we also have office hours
I think it's 3:30
so pretty much soon after this talk if
you want to come and discuss with any of
us the topics you've been through today
another resource that you can look at
when you're back home is on the play
Academy where we offer free training to
all developers it was built to help you
understand best practices and features
to help you succeed on play and we have
dedicated content on there from this
year's i/o so to wrap up I just want to
repeat what I said at the start
quality is a job that is never done for
as long as Android continues to evolve
for as long as new form factors are
created and you developers continue to
innovate
we have the potential to create all
kinds of amazing capabilities and
experiences for users and throughout all
these changes the thing that remains
constant for us is to maintain an
increase the baseline for quality on
Android so you should expect to see us
again here next year and at many other
events in between
please also do keep sharing your
feedback with us in the meantime and
help us partner with you on this long
term journey thank you very much for
listening
[Music]
[Applause]